Philadelphia Pennsylvania baby have we
got good news for you we just added a
second show down there at the Fillmore
for December yeah gang you guys were
awesome the Army garbage came correct we
sold out the first show four months
before the freaking show so we added
another let's do it again baby tickets
on sale right now at Ru garbage.com
tickets on sale right now for all other
cities on the state trashy Tour on our
website links in the description get
them do it welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody out
there and welcome back to everybody's
new favorite podcast this is are you
garbage oh yeah it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out if they're good to be
classy after just a big old piece of
trash I'm your host stage Foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're out back
here at titties in the new edition she's
out front just saw her get tased by the
cops okay not getting into that Mike
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me
rather than a joke
he is the CEO of are you garbage he is
an international businessman but at
night he turns into the flatbread freak
give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan what
up gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate you subscribe
on iTunes full video of album on YouTube
as you know those numbers are true to
roof cooking baby and obviously the
greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage gang you
sign up over there you become one of
over we're closing on an 11 000 [__]
patrons right now join the [__] Army
of garbage gang love that money and how
about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
the twos the threes and the fours he
crosses the t's and he dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen everybody what up dudes what's
up pal I'm excited our guests came in
from beautiful Austin Texas yeah a
little bit of Touch of Class until she
said she like Mayo on her hot dogs about
30 seconds into meter yeah
a fun one
gang the long hair ain't lying because
we couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guests here with us today for the first
time she's a very funny comedian actor
and podcaster and you may have seen her
in but not limited to you got clown town
I'm dying up here companion Death House
Here and Now Golden State Once Upon a
Time in Deadwood in 2023 is your honor
with Mr Brian Cranston and she has a
brand new podcast first date show over
there at ymh Studios give it up for
Lauren Compton everybody hey buddy
[Applause]
thanks for coming in yeah uh give us a
little bit of the uh the origin story
here what's the back story tell us the
whole deal where are you born where Were
You Raised I was born in Dallas Texas
okay okay
um raised in Mesquite Texas okay where's
that at it's like I only know it as a
flavor
so you're gonna have to give me some
coordinates here just the connection of
the ghetto okay
um straight that way
um I was homeschooled well all right
okay slow it down take it nice and slow
around here slow down homeschool I think
you're the first homeschool person we've
had on the show in 400 [__] episodes
grew up in charcoal town and was
homeschooled yes uh okay at what age did
that start the whole time all the way
through
um I was homeschooled until I was 16.
then went to high school and then I went
to a private school okay every year and
then I went to a public school for six
months oh this girl's trash
and then I went to an alternative school
for six weeks
and then I moved to the safest place on
Earth Hollywood California okay okay all
right back this up all right uh hold on
wow why was why was homeschool the
option I was an elite gymnast okay all
right all right okay so I would train
from 6 30 a.m to noon okay I'd have
lunch from noon to one and then I would
go upstairs in our gym we had an English
PhD who would teach the six girls on the
team uh school for four hours so not
your mom wasn't teaching you math at the
kitchen table I thought this was like
Hillbillies yeah I thought there was
like goats running around
okay all right well that's that's very
classy born in God would you would have
been instructors and stuff what'd your
parents do my mom was a nurse okay yeah
she retired and then my dad was a
computer engineer okay so why did you
guys move from Dallas to Mesquite was
that because of the gymnastics I was
just born in Dallas I grew up in
Mesquite okay all right so you're from
there they find out that you're a good
gymnast yeah so you start the the path
of becoming an Olympian an Olympian yeah
so I went to like one of the highest and
strictest schools for gymnastics okay
and um when did they discover this like
when did you when did you find something
you start early right yeah you started
like two and three you're doing I
started it at nine whoa damn yeah I
tried everything else and nothing were
you regularly schooled until nine uh did
you go to kindergarten stuff like that I
don't I went to like eighth grade
regular as a normal okay school okay and
then I got pulled out in eighth grade
because they saw some potential because
I started taking gymnastics super
seriously okay huh that's not a cheap
sport either that's expensive it was so
expensive it was 500 a month and this
was like way back then sure 500 bucks a
month for the school and 500 bucks a
month for the gym so it was a thousand
dollars a month okay to put me through
this process and way back then that was
a lot of money especially for my family
I grew up pretty poor
okay what was the house situation like
was it uh only child only child yep
parents worked only child single family
home like like a like a house yeah a
house do you have a garage we did have a
garage yeah what kind of acreage are we
talking about I think it was just in a
neighborhood where I don't even know if
we had an acre I don't even have an acre
okay it's just a regular residential
normal gotcha Suburban neighborhood
would you park the cars in the garage
yes okay park the cars on the lawn in
the garage in the garage okay was there
a refrigerator in that garage no
how long did you do the gymnastics still
I did gymnastics till I was 16. uh I
blew my knee out a couple of times okay
so I've got like a wine I got this one
and I've got this oh damn so that kind
of put an end to the gymnastics yeah you
think it's 16. what the [__] I did it
it's a bionic man over here when I was
14 and then I did it when I was 15 and
then 16 and the doctor was like the next
time it's not going to be your knee it's
going to be your neck and then my dad
was like you're done how'd you blow out
the knee what was it on first time it
was on the balance beam I fell it was
really bad I was doing a Dismount I
won't even go through it with you
if I think about it
what was your
uh event
I was an all-around so you would do the
whole thing could you do the floor thing
where you spin around and all that stuff
floor beam and bars Vault I sucked at
Vault okay
yeah how about the Pummel horse that's
for boys
damn is that what you're here because I
couldn't get any chicks out there
the Rings are just for guys too yeah
really yeah the uneven parallel bars the
balance beam the floor and the Vault are
the four so you did the thing where you
spin around and then like your waist
would hit the lower one and you spin
back around and you would jump from one
to the other yeah bam dude I loved it I
was really good at it until I fell okay
huh that's pretty classy it's not tree
yeah it's not trash yes were there any
pets growing up
um I had a cat but then my dad backed
over it with the truck okay
all right and I had it and then I had a
dog named Casper who killed him he just
died old age yeah I'm a horse accident
yeah
blew out his name uh what was uh what
was the family whip would you guys drive
around in
um my mom had a Volkswagen Beetle okay
old school one a new one okay one of the
new ones like 2004 yeah
got in a car accident and my dad was
like no more accordion cars sure so then
she went for the new one what was the
color yellow they're always yellow
yellow but when you were a little kid
your mom was whipping around in an old
school he has she still to this day has
a Volkswagen Beetle she's had black or
yellow beetles my whole life life and
what's your pop driving
he's driving a Mustang really yeah like
a good one or like oh [__] he was
tinkering with it no he loved car okay
so he had like a Stingray Corvette that
was gold with leopard interior all right
he said you were poor well that was when
he was growing up okay but he had cars
throughout his life he was a car you
know how like when you don't have a lot
of money but you have one thing sure
yeah and a lot of car guys is that all
their time and money goes into the car
he had cars and guns okay and that was
that sounds all right
[__] Stingray let's go yeah my dad
was a badass okay growing up did you
have any cars around the house that
didn't run that were maybe getting
worked on quote unquote No I wish I
would have that would have I feel like
that would be so credible sure but no my
dad was like pretty good at keeping his
car running a tight shoe he would show
it in car shows there's a car show guy
he was a car show guy and he was in the
SVT mustang club and so he had all of
his little friends that had Mustangs and
then they would have like group calls
was it an old Mustang or a new Mustang
it was the one that he had last was a
Mach 3 Mustang and it was a new one damn
oh it sounds cool yeah it sounds like a
plane we were broke because of his hat
bits okay okay I respect that what was
the name of the grocery store that you
went to growing up uh Albertsons
Albertsons suspect very respectable do
you guys still do they still live in the
same house that you grew up in no
um my mom now lives in Pennsylvania with
her sister my dad passed away when in
2012. okay I'm sorry to hear that I
already hear that that's okay what was
the name of the street that you grew up
on then Bill Shaw the address was 625
Bill Shaw Drive Bill Shaw Drive I don't
know I don't know it sounds like a
wrestler or something
that's Bill Shaw from the top row I
loved the WWE Smackdown did you ever oh
I was obsessed with that Triple H was my
[__] huh shout out to Triple H dude she
liked it for the acrobatics
these guys in Stone Cold Steve Austin
don't even get my he was old he was a
hero of mine for a very long let me tell
you what Thursday nights nothing would
come in the way of me and WWE okay
that's not yeah that's a blemish in the
files you're starting to add up yeah I
don't know I can't get a read on her uh
as an athlete
um were you drinking you're drinking
Gatorade back then right yeah Gatorade
water favorite flavor of Gatorade I do
not like anything grape or cherry so the
yellow one yellow one okay
it's called lemon lime yeah yeah enough
yeah
all right what'd you call your
grandparents [__]
dumb [__] and jerk off now check that
one off all right
huh were you close with any extended
family Aunts Uncles was anybody around
or was it just you guys out there in
Mesquite Texas no everyone hated us yeah
wait why I don't know I I grew up with
this like privilege of being
homeschooled and uh an elite gymnast and
all this stuff and my cousins on my
mom's side [__] just thought they
would make fun of me for being The
Golden Child and so they really really
did not but they lived in this in the
general area they were from luckily they
lived in California okay so they were
far enough away that I didn't have to
give a [__] okay but then when I would
see them they would like put me on a
scooter and clip the break thing and
send me down a hill with speed bumps
what the [__] they were mean clipping
the brakes on your scooter and sending
me down a hill with speed bumps I will
never forget that
they put a car bomb on my power Wheel
I can't believe I'm here today I
survived my family sounds like you grew
up in the 1820s
Florida [__] bad blood with the family
okay and then no one on my dad's side is
around at all
um I have my mom and my aunt and that's
it gotcha yeah and they're in PA yes
very nice all right
um what were the vacations like growing
up none no vacations the only time I
traveled was for my gymnastics
competitions okay and
um I think the furthest I went was
Arizona
okay
I'm sorry I don't need to show you guys
that Arizona
um okay but I did I would go to
California with my mom sometimes so that
she could visit her family but I never
took a family like my dad never went
anywhere with us
no Disneyland no down to the lake house
no lake house man this is really shaping
up yeah I'm sorry you guys no this is no
this is what this is what we're here for
uh hmm were you an Applebee's family or
any any corporate chain restaurants
growing up or were you doing local
little stuff did you ever go so our
highlight was on the border
the Mexican restaurant well you are in
Texas I know you're literally On the
Border yeah
so we'd go to On the Border
um just love that chipotle I don't know
what it is or Waffle House yeah do you
want to talk about breakfast like a
treat and covered of course
All-Star special huh pecans and my
waffles I'm also allergic to pecans but
I didn't give a [__] how allergic like
if I take them I my mouth will break out
and you would eat them anyway yeah I
didn't care okay zero [__] here we go
we ever kicked out of a restaurant as a
family has to leave
um yeah my dad got wasted one time all
right your dad sounds pretty cool yeah
and and uh it was we were at soup and
salad and it was like a buffet style
chain and you go in and it's like a
buffet of soups and a buffet of salads a
buffet is soup soups and salads it was
called soup and salad perfect on a hot
Texas day and my dad was like wasted and
we were sitting in the booth and he was
making vomiting sounds because he
thought the food sucked so much and my
mom kept telling them to stop and I was
like oh what's happening and they just
got so annoyed with my parents that they
told us to leave
[Laughter]
would you guys eat dinner as a family as
a kid would you sit down at the table
and eat yes you would yes okay I
remember one time my mom slaved in the
kitchen to cook this meal okay and my
dad uh came home and he was just in a
bad mood and he looks at this dinner
that was like just the whole table and
he goes I'm not hungry and he went
upstairs and my mom was living I would
lose it so the next two weeks well after
that after that he went to Whataburger
to get food like two hours later because
my mom had cleared the table sure so
then he got hungry went to Whataburger
then for the next two weeks every time
he'd come home my mom would have a bag
of Whataburger on the table
until he apologized
and so he got so tired of Whataburger
that he was like I'm so sorry I will
never do that again and then my mom went
back to cooking that's damn family's
[__] vindictive that's an emotional
pressure cooker you grew up in and
that's the side that tried to kill you
right
then my mom said yes yes yeah Christ
you're like your Whataburger so much why
don't you marry you
uh-huh okay was she was your mom a good
cook yeah what would you cook she would
make Italian food Mexican food homemade
tacos spaghetti her own Ragu Sauce okay
yeah Mom was a cooker what were the
holidays like Thanksgiving Christmas
they had my dad had two friends okay Al
and Judy his wife and his brother I
don't remember his brother's name I
forgot I think I'm just traumatized from
there that group of people sure but they
would come over and that was all that it
was ever for Thanksgiving and Christmas
just there good presents in the morning
though right on Christmas yeah yeah well
it's uh well the lights on the tree were
they colored or were they white colored
colored lights on except for one year my
mom wanted to do an all-white thing and
she did pearls and white lights and she
got seashells from the beach in
California and she thought it'd be a
really good idea to like bleach them and
put glitter on them but they smelt Jesus
like the ocean for [__] Christmas
morning smells like low tide for weeks
damn and our whole house just smelled
like fish dead fish that'll ruin a
[__] it was Christmas it doesn't
matter what kind of gingerbread cookies
you make man the gymnastics was real
misleading I'll tell you that right
private tutors
on Christmas
huh uh what about on the outside of the
house would you do would your dad
decorate colored lights out there
um we never really did anything outside
really yeah we just had a tree and a
couple of decorations maybe a Garland on
the stairwell man you were that house
huh yeah
we looked unhappy pick it up on that
huh
vacations no nothing
uh so when you started High School
what was the name of the high school
that you went to the one year in a
private school was called Dallas
Christian and what happened to that that
you only went there for a year
um
um oh
my so I told you I didn't have a lot of
money yeah so my 16th birthday came
along and I wanted a car and I told my
dad I said dad just you can get me
anything you want just please don't get
me a truck okay and please don't get me
anything like whatever you do just get
me a black car I wanted a black car and
I didn't care what it was and on my
birthday I walked outside my dad was
like I got you a surprise outside I was
like oh my God it's gonna be a really
cool car and I go out and say champagne
gold
S10 mini truck that's all right
and I just had cried my eyes out and I
was like it looks like a penis and I was
like I can't drive that to this fancy
private school sure like that it has
like hydraulics in it
I wish I could have it would have been
like a really cool like low whatever low
rider so anyway I hated this car so much
I didn't talk to my dad for like three
months okay because he I felt like he
made me ride in this awful car and
everyone made fun of me okay so then my
dad came to me and he said you have a
choice we can either sell the car and
I'll get you a black Volkswagen Beetle
but you have to go to public school
because I can't afford both okay or you
can stay in school and drive the truck
and I was like will obviously give me
the better car Jesus so he got me a
black Volkswagen I got pulled out of
private school I went to public school
and it was so bad the public school the
public school you didn't know how good
you had it no idea you're out there
cruising around in a Cool Whip to a
private school next thing you know
you're [__] you're you're in there
and with the [__] with the bums yeah
so the answer is you wanted a car I
wanted a nice car it wasn't you got in
trouble your grade something something
respectable something had to give and
then I hated the public school so much
that I got in with the wrong group of
friends hey we all been there yeah okay
crocheted at you for that I'm in with
three of them right now for a long time
I was the wrong group of friends this
episode is brought to you by betterhelp
gang we all need a little advice that'll
help every once in a while and better
help can help it is easy you can do it
right from your home in the Privacy your
own home as you know I'm Screwballs as
they come sure are trying to find a
therapist uh been striking out had
signed up for better help needed some
help gave him a call came over change my
oil nice little chat yeah nice little
chat do video you do text you do call
it's absolutely fantastic uh yeah I've
always said big uh it's nuts Big Talk
therapy guy I think it's a fantastic
tool to use either weekly or you know
just through tough times of your life
definitely check it the [__] out gang
get some help better help is designed to
be flexible convenient and suited to
your schedule so you can have your
sessions whenever and wherever works for
you you can choose to have a video call
phone call or even just message with
your therapist totally up to you let
therapy be your map with better help
visit better help.com slash garbage
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash garbage betterhelp.com
garbage do it gang okay let's talk about
trust and will oh baby shout out to
trust and will gang you're gonna feel
real stupid rotten in hell that's where
I'm gonna be while everybody's [__]
ransex my [__] everybody's stealing my
[__] cool gear and I'm turning over
I'm sitting playing poker with the devil
who do you think's gonna take that bag
of weed that you left in your sock
drawer gang you want to make sure that
you get everything squared away and
trust and will is the way to go you can
create and manage your will or Trust
online you're ensuring that your family
is prepared and protected plus you keep
the vultures away creeps coming in a
bunch of everybody the [__] everybody
comes creeping out of the Woodworks a
second I'm starting rooting around for
the freezer for the gold uh each wheel
of trust is created to be State specific
and customized to your needs you can
plan out all your cares and wishes
nominate Guardians specify final
arrangements and appoint a power of
attorney Kip that's all you that's what
I need for I need power of attorney for
you you gotta be signing up for time
shares left and right
gangs getting a will is one of those
things that lingers over your head
towards we're all getting older not
everybody's in great shape myself
included they gotta crossed off off the
list baby just you sleep a little better
at night with thousands of five star
ratings on trustpilot you're in good
hands with trust and will don't let the
state decide what happens to your assets
yeah think about that come over start
because you're [__] chopping up your
cheese sandwich collection uh make sure
make the right choice with trust and
will gain peace of mind today with trust
and we'll get 10 off plus free shipping
of your estate plan documents by
visiting trust and will.com garbage
that's 10 off and free shipping at
trustandwill.com garbage do it gang I
would ditch school and I would go to the
mall with my girlfriends and we would
steal really cheap jewelry from like
like Claire's or the icing every chick
did that for every girl at some point
got arrested at the mall for stealing
yeah from Claire's I remember the the
thing that got me I stole a pair of
fossil sunglasses from like Dillard's
and uh that was my big steal the big
score that was my big one I was like oh
my God and they caught me on the cameras
and the security guard came after me and
put us in little Mall prison did you try
to run I did nice it didn't work should
have done a somersault over the fountain
or something you probably could have
beat them up
yeah and so then they called my mom my
mom had to come get me from like Mall
prison and then my car got taken away
sure rightfully so you're [__] out
there stealer I know wait the cops
impounded it no her parents took my car
away it was an accessory to a crime and
so that's why six months of public
school was only six months and then they
were like we got to get you out of this
situation
um so he put me in an alternative school
and that's like where you either like
stab someone as a juvenile or you get
pregnant or you steal them all or you're
a real criminal so I was like in this
criminal school okay and I when I
sharpened my Skittles
I was really that's when I learned bed
fraud
that's where I met my first boyfriend
okay I'm kidding I'm kidding okay
um and so I graduated within six weeks
with a GED
and on my 18th birthday wait so you have
a GED yeah
oh I never even like really properly
graduated did you take the SATs or the
no nothing GED I got a GED so you didn't
go to college you weren't planning on
going to college I went to Hooters and I
got a job
man this is [__] shape it up all
right winter Hooters another place
called Bone Daddy's okay okay so I went
from Hooters to Bone Daddy's wait hold
on what's that a financial services
what do they do 401ks annuities sugar
daddies
so you became a mortgage broker
wait hold on this is right out of high
so alternative school's over you get
your GED you go to Hooters were there
any sports at the uh at the alternative
school or anything like that no I never
did another sport ever again sports at
the alternative I don't know I'm trying
to get my head around dude alternative
school is a it is a square room where
everybody's physical it was like dodging
bullets only sport the the life that
you're describing is how assassins are
made yeah pretty much that that's the
picture that I'm getting here yeah so
you so you you get out of there GED you
go and you go and work at a Hooters yep
and then I make enough money to buy a
sports car and then I take it I mean
yeah girls got priorities what was the
sports car family took my car away and I
was like well [__] you did you ever get
the beetle back no that's why how are
you getting to and from Hooters your
parents are dropping you off at Hooters
no I would just I would figure it out
okay I made a lot of money pretty quick
okay I know I know I had a I had a
friend who worked at Hooters right out
of uh high school as well I also cleaned
up I also did dates talking about me
that would give me rides nice yeah so I
had a boyfriend with a car okay what was
the age difference there because this
this screams five years same age we met
in the high school that I went to he
went to a different high school but we
met at a party okay yeah all right well
he came in and hang out while you were
working
yeah he would sometimes just to like
make sure sure yeah did you have did you
ever have regulars that came in oh yeah
I would ask to be sat in your section I
had this guy named Neil that would come
in classic needle and Neil would come in
older guy he was older married he was
engaged but he was one of those guys
that would pick up money from illegal
poker tournaments okay do you know what
I'm talking about if you have like an
underground poker tournament sure and
there's this collectors that drive
around and they collect money okay he
was one of those okay and he would tip
me seven hundred dollars
on wings are they hired what's going on
here 17 bucks and he tipped me 700 and
he would come in once a week really yeah
this is to let you know I'm desperate
this guy's gonna come and whack us what
are you doing
I had another guy that would come in his
name was Bobby and he one time asked if
I would be his date to an event he was
trying to make all of his buddies
jealous and he paid me like three
thousand dollars that was like my first
call girl first and only call girl did
you go you did it I went with him to the
party yeah like a proper term it was
like just to go with him to a party and
then afterwards I went home yeah but
isn't that what a typical an escort I
didn't mean in the the sex worker way
yeah like to accompany you the escort
yeah how old was he was he older he was
in his 30s okay and I wasn't even 18.
Jesus okay all right but he paid me
three thousand dollars I would do it now
go to a party which has to be illegal it
was for sure
it's frowned upon I know that I don't
know the local Commonwealth of Mesquite
uh walls but it ain't did it and did it
work or were his friends like who is
this girl what's going on I so I have
known this guy you need help
no I'm saying they're coming up party
he was so nice I mean I mean I guess
what else would he have been but yeah
yeah it wasn't cool he could have killed
you he totally could have killed you I
just watched a documentary on that
I was like coming out of alternative
school I was like you want to pay me
three grand to go to a party [__] I go
buy my I'd go for free yeah I mean 17.
I'm over here trying to like Rob
Claire's yeah I hey I'm not hating I
don't I'm not hating the player so those
are the two regulars that I ever had how
long did you work at Hooters
not very long a couple of months couple
of months you were 17. and then you went
to boneheads then you went to the Bone
Daddy's bone daddy similar type of
establishments yeah because on my 18th
birthday I moved to LA that was it gone
I took my money I took my car small town
girl getting out of Mesquite I got out
of hashing it all in went straight to
Hollywood California oh nice and that's
when I got recruited for my brains at
Playboy okay okay okay
very similar story to my friend Hooters
to Playboy she went it's a very seems to
be a lateral move yeah like uh sorry you
were talking about me
you go to Hooters and read Playboy okay
what year was that
so I didn't do Playboy until I was just
turned 21. so 18
19 20 21 so I was in California for
about three years I went to a community
college I took all the fun classes there
you go one of the fun classes I took
Shakespearean literature biblical
literature English literature
and theater nice okay and then I had to
take Math and Science and that's when I
quit Okay so no associates degree to go
with that GED okay nope man but I know
how to write a really good book
you can read the [__] out of the Bible
I'll interpret that [__] like no
one's business I know where to get bad
weed if you need it
all right okay all right so that's the
tail huh and then I wrote a book of
poetry okay and I got it self-published
okay I thought I was gonna be the next
Shakespeare uh-huh I sold one copy on
the boardwalk in Venice to a guy named
Neil who played nine grand for us
[Applause]
long hairs on today boys look out
um and it was just a skateboarder that
felt bad for me and said he had seen me
out there all day long and he just
wanted to I don't need the book man I
don't need the book go get a bowl of
soup or something will you wait where
were you selling it on the boardwalk
like you know like a lemonade stand yeah
you know what she also said she got it
self-published I had 500 copies made
because I was like I'm gonna sell out
the first day I need to have stock they
were all hand written
laughs holy [__] Lauren and so yeah I
sold one copy I still have a duffel bag
full of 499 more there you go yeah it
was called
[Laughter]
cases.com a couple of paperbacks wait
what was the name of it cases of a poet
cases of a poet don't worry it's nowhere
online that's not a bad yeah still
analog I like it
lose the art form online
okay huh I respect the hustle though I
really respect the horse of course of
course all right let's uh let's switch
gears talk about now okay all right
doing well yeah you down there you're
down there in Austin
um
was there any stupid purchases at any
time when you would get a check when you
started when you started making
something take that Playboy check
because you know were you doing like the
appearances and stuff hold on what was
the sports car that you bought though oh
I got a Chrysler Crossfire that's not a
sports score my mom drove a Chrysler a
crossfire the little thing the little
thing I don't mess now you sound like my
dad yeah exactly people who drive sports
cars not myself would call that T-Bone I
don't think so this is one of those
Chrysler moves where it tries to look
like a Mercedes yeah I try it's like the
300 it's the you know it looks like it
looks like a sports car though it's next
to a sports car yeah if I can quote Mr
Cow Williams yeah it looks like you own
a minor league team maybe right and then
my my sugar daddy Bobby ended up putting
six thousand dollars down on it as my
down payment
Bobby from the party man Bobby loved me
poor Bobby never got any [__] though
they never do he didn't
took Batman for everything he had really
not everything he was very rich I just I
took like 10 grand
okay hey that's all right those guys the
guy they like that though they like
being the sugar Dad they they like
giving uh you know young uh pretty women
nice thing all right I myself don't like
doing that the grifting's gonna be a
strike against you I'm not gonna lie but
I respect it the GED ain't helping
either
the crossfire I mean that's like lottery
winner [__]
oh man Chevy crossbow zipping around L.A
all right so after the crossfire were
there any other stupid purchases where
you were like if you got to check for a
couple Grand or whatever and you're like
I shouldn't have spent half of that on
I mean
I I took trips I respect that that's
good where'd you go
Tallahassee Ohio
um yeah I went to Italy I lived in Italy
for a year that's awesome I did all
right learned how to speak the language
what uh what city in Italy bologna ah
always favorite Town
Oscar Meyer so you speak fluent Italian
uh-huh that's pretty good yep pretty
good wanna Pizza
second language
I was like I think I understood that
maybe I know more Italian than I think
she just goes hey how you doing
all right you speak Italian that's
pretty good you lived in Italy for a
year not bad
um
I would buy other people gifts
that's classy you would buy other people
like what give me an example like [__]
that they could never like like my
girlfriend has a fashion line and I
funded the whole thing okay or my dad
wanted you to get points on it are you a
part of are you an investor or you just
gave her the money as a loan um I gave
her the money initially and I was like I
just want you to go be successful
so that that had nothing on it but then
I also invested in a restaurant and I
have a return investment on that really
what restaurant plug it he built up a
cup of soup and salad franchise Max
husband is the manager okay okay it's in
Venice California it's called um I don't
even remember what it's called
but stuff like that like I don't even
think about it and I'm just like how
much money do you need okay
but but for people that I really love I
will do very lavish so you've been
making money for a while a couple of
bucks on you yeah doing all right yeah
where'd you guys get married
Vegas
I can't get a [__] read on it what
are you talking about
oh there's gonna be something classy I
don't know restaurant here fashion lines
in Vegas those were personal loans yeah
she's probably charging a veg on it you
remember [__] poor Bobby she's gonna
send Neil to collect
hold on you guys met in Vegas yep so we
went back to Vegas two years later to
get married okay well venue in Vegas did
you get married out a drive-through okay
all right we went through a
drive-through and we had a Pamela
Anderson look alike
and then it's pretty good my mom found
out that we had done that what Pam
Anderson like like a trashy one
like the barbed wire one was that the
movie it was like yeah barbed wire she
was wearing like a wife beater Okay that
Pam Anderson yeah very have you ever
seen the drive-through weddings uh not
in person it's like McDonald's there's a
menu so when you drive up they're like
okay do you want the number one which is
like you drive through you say your vows
you drive off do you want the number two
we give you a candle that you both can
light together or the number three we
also give you a bouquet and a headdress
and you are in your car speaking to a
drive-up window damn and so we did that
and then my my are you in the crossbow
when this is going on no we were in
um I had turned that car in and got a
Volkswagen a yellow one a beetle yeah
man hit the Beetles it's crazy yeah and
you were you were doing well then right
Courtney I was doing pretty good you
just like the Beatles I loved the
Beatles what are you driving in now I
have a BMW nice
that ain't yellow it's not nice all
right very good
um what was the ice like that you got
from from your ring was he was he a man
of wealth and taste this one right here
this little tiny itty bitty one was that
the engagement ring that was all I had
huh that was the cute little ring and
then after being married for like three
years he got me one that was like a
little bit bigger that looked like a
braid of diamonds from Tiffany's and
that's just in my jewelry box but this
one is just so cute I mean I have to
like
all right sure sure huh but never had
like a big rock or anything
never and he let you keep the engagement
there was never a thing about that well
he cheated on me okay all right it
wasn't like he got anything back he gave
me chlamydia okay
you met him in Vegas what do you expect
I mean like like [__] [__] okay
hmm yeah I got more than I bargained for
trust me man we are all over the map
with this one man uh uh huh what was the
last dinner you cooked
um the last dinner I made was Thomas
Keller's buttered Lobster and orzo mac
and cheese
and then the one before that was Gordon
Ramsay's duck with Thomas Keller's Palm
parade he did the recipe oh
so I've been practicing my Gourmet
cooking skills nice yeah right so you so
you cook for yourself at the house me
and my boyfriend nice all right he owns
a barbecue restaurant okay so sometimes
he brings home barbecue and then mix it
into the homemade pasta shells and stuff
like that it's pretty delicious that's
homemade pasta you're doing oh yeah wow
I love to cook it's my favorite little
hobby uh we were talking about Mayo
before we started recording uh is it
Hellman's or is it Miracle Whip ew no no
Miracle Whip Rose
I have trust issues with people who like
Miracle Whip excellent excellent
excellent everything that's the first
right answer I think we got out of you
so you got you got you speak Italian and
you got and you got Mayo yeah so far
love Mayo you asked for another table at
a restaurant
what will you ask for another table at a
restaurant if you get sat and you're
like I have this I don't like this will
you ask to be moved no okay you're cool
with it yeah I'm fine what about a hotel
room
but he has to move a hotel room no I I
look online at what I'm booking yeah but
sometimes you get one I've learned from
you you get one next to the elevator and
people like never take that like if you
get up there in your room 402 and it's
right next to the elevator yeah because
people you'll hear it all night I
typically don't do that because I'll
pass out drinking so yeah I don't matter
no I've never uh okay
uh-uh I'll return food if it looks
[__] up sure if it's if it's egregious
of course yeah sure how do you get your
steak cooked rare
I want it to Moo at me okay and then I
also swirl it around and it's sauces
will you bring food onto the plane with
you
no I like going to the airport and
indulging yes of course right to go a
little early of course have a drink or
two sure eat something naughty sure have
those tater tots with cheese sure
you're speaking my language well you put
your seat back on the plane before we
even take off
I gotta make sure that we keep things
spicy okay if that plane goes down I
want to know it was my fault all right
keep how about that butcher box shout
out to the mfn butcher Biz Ox baby big
fans over here at Ru garbage you butcher
box gang put your box for talking top
Quality Meats and Seafood delivered
right to your door you can trust them
can't always trust that stuff at the
grocery store you got some kid putting
the stickers over it we're talking
grass-fed grass finish we're talking
wild caught we're talking free range do
yourself a favor get on butcher box get
meat delivered right to your door yeah
they've uh the good Folks at butcher box
have been nothing but sweet to us
nothing but good uh shipping me I mean
pallets of [__] bacon a ground beef
hamburger meat whatever you need there's
an addition on my house all ground beef
that's how much meat they say I turned
the second walk in the second bedroom to
a walk-in freezer if you're looking for
recipe ideas you'll get tons of guides
and tips hacks to make the best meals
ever butcher boxes giving us a special
deal so strap in nuts sign up at
putyourbox.com
ayg and use code ayg to get salmon for
three months man there you go eating
like a goddamn grizzly in here plus 20
bucks off your first order that's
butcherbox.com
ayg use the code ayg to clean this deal
do it gang links in an ocean how to deal
come back to the show back to the show
how do you say say you're at home you're
cooking you use half an avocado how do
you save the other half
[Music]
just put it in the fridge raw dog do you
cover it in tin foil Saran Wrap you have
one of those nice little I would say
Saran wrap it but I'd make sure that the
seed is in the part that I save gotta
stay in there
and then I'd probably put some Saran
wrap on it and save it okay uh what kind
of fridge are we working with at the
house just a normal normal fridge one
silver yeah stainless steel stainless
steel what's the vacuum situation Dyson
that long stick one oh it's my favorite
toy pretty good where are you shopping
now grocery wise where do you go down
there in Austin there's a place called
Central Market it's nice it's a fancy
place but with the meals that I've been
making I have to have like some kind of
specific good stuff otherwise I'd just
go anywhere but other places don't
really have the imported things what's
the big one down there HEB HEB yeah
they're all right they're the ones that
don't really have the imported stuff
they have America all right you're in
[__] God's country down there yeah
we're not bringing in Italian stuff I
like HEB that's where we instant card
all the stuff when we were down there I
like HEB too
um what's the credit like what's your
credit score I don't know should we
check it not right now
good enough that it's not a problem it's
not problem okay what kind of plastic
are you throwing around you got an MX my
boobs are real oh
um good to know Amex I do have an Amex
nice yeah business Platinum it's one of
those metal cards
they know I drop it to let them know
yeah watch your toes
yeah better be steel toe boots you got
on I sharpened mine and throw it against
the wall like a throwing star nice
um any Capital One Discover Cards
anything like that I only use my AmEx
you have a checkbook no okay I just got
one
um are you uh say you're going to a
friend's house for dinner right and
you're bringing are you gonna bring
something like a bottle of wine I'm the
chef
uh wait you're bringing food or they're
coming to you first of all I don't have
that many friends okay so like
Thanksgiving and things like that people
are coming okay let's say you were going
over you know uh sagoras Tom's house
yeah like hey come over we're having
dinner or whatever for team dinner yep
you're coming you're not gonna come
empty-handed I presume you're somewhat
of a pretty classy broad I would bring a
bottle of champagne a bottle of red and
I would make homemade stuffed
conquilioni shells with sausage
Mortadella Ricotta and parmesan cheese
with a bechamel sauce baked in the oven
at 350 degrees with Parmesan crusted
layers we're actually having a party
tonight
so good yeah that's I mean that's man
your history was just wiped clean yeah
talk about a [__] reset in the
Mainframe all I heard was a bottle of
red and hot appetizers yes
yes and the Platinum Card ain't killing
me either the entrance I like to make
okay all right I like that good on that
if we came over to your house right now
if we were over at the house uh and you
offered us a glass of water what would
we be getting we'd be getting out of the
tap would be getting a bottle a bottle
Pellegrino you'd be offered a Pellegrino
yeah cold Pellegrino I like sparkling
water you got the big bottle or the
little big one because usually if I pour
you a glass I'm gonna want some too nice
okay uh we're Pellegrino people as well
when you go to the restaurant is it
sparkling still or tap it depends if I'm
getting champagne if I'm getting
champagne I don't do sparkling water
because I'm having a sparkling wine okay
so I'll drink normal tap water and I
usually always ask for tap water because
I don't want to pay Seven dollars for a
normal bottle of water okay uh and what
is the drink what is your go-to drink
you're going out long extra dirty filthy
awfully terrible dirty gin martini gin I
do vodka but I got a real problem with
them I want to crush them yeah oh God I
can throw it back yeah they're the best
you know I got [__] up on those
because I thought they were zero
calories I was like oh there's like 200
calories 100 calories I was trying to
like take it easy on the wine and I was
like oh you know what this is just
liquor there's no carbs calories in this
so it's all that goddamn olive juice my
goodness and I like it yeah healthy yeah
me too so
you have blue cheese olives or regular
olives blue cheese really you have any
on you I want it disgusting make that
like a [__] drink gotcha nasty you ever
been to a timeshare pitch yep really
uh-huh Vegas
would you win for it it was like a
three-day thing and I won a raffle which
is so [__] up that you have to win a
raffle to go to a timeshare everyone
wins the rap what where did you win the
raffle I was at a car show
oh
this is like Inception of trash
it was inside a Walmart
spin something on the table I don't know
what's going on all right now the
Inception I gotcha thank you uh do you
know how to use chopsticks yes okay hmm
you send any venmo requests no I never
send the request I only get requested
gotcha everyone's trying to sure what
their beaks a little bit uh what kind of
luggage are you using to me
she paints do you pee in the shower all
the time you brush your teeth in there
yes and if you ever take a shower with
me I'll pee on your foot okay good to
know but if you leave the toothbrush in
there
um
no I imagine the apartment is nice is
like put together it's nice yes yes it's
clean king-sized bed oh yeah nice
pillows all that kind of stuff
um like a hundred pillows okay my
boyfriend's big so he has to have his
own gotcha inside you guys sleep with a
fan on you there's a fan for noise as
weird as that sounds okay White Noise
sure but we sleep with it cold as [__]
nice fall asleep with the TV on there's
not even a TV in the bedroom
are you reading anything right now not
Twitter that's a good book all right
halfway through okay do you guys live
together or is it your place you live
together okay yeah I invaded his space
so it's pretty serious I guess
shows over
thanks for coming by
don't show that's the only time we have
this week do you have a favorite cup at
the house
um this is gonna sound so silly but I
have a ymh made uh first date martini
glasses okay I saw those actually yes
our it's my one piece of merch and I
know it sounds stupid and I'm not even
doing it for a plug but that's my
favorite glass in the house I'll drink
Sparkling water out of it because I've
never had merch before in my whole life
so having it you had the book what are
you talking about no that was a that was
a mistake all right
um yeah so that's my actually my
favorite glass that I drink out of I
drink everything out of it you guys have
a little bar set up at the house no we
live in a kind of small apartment
where do you get where are you guys
eating dinner if you're having dinner
together
oh at the table you mean at home at home
at home we like if you make dinner he
comes home so we have an island okay
that has two chairs okay and so um and
then we have a couch and we do have a
dinner table if it's really nice the
table the table sure you set the table
yeah sure and we have candles and it's
like a romantic thing will you guys sit
and eat dinner and watch TV together
he doesn't watch TV really yeah he reads
he reads yeah and then I play Candy
Crush
still oh yeah Jesus Christ I'm
practicing being a grandma
all right huh do you keep your ketchup
uh in the fridge or in the counter
fridge where do you keep the butter top
shelf in the door on the right okay and
I use European butter
what butter what does that mean it's
like kerrygold yeah Irish okay yeah very
classy yeah I never heard somebody refer
to as European butter it is European
butter though sure I'll give you that
theoretic I mean but yeah sure okay
where do you like to go on vacation now
um I just got back from a huge trip I
went to Barcelona and then Croatia and
then Soho Farmhouse and then London very
and I just got back like two weeks ago
nice nice yeah all right my next trip is
my birthday trip in October and I'm
going to the Marrakesh okay very nice
yes very cool I hear good things all
right but I love to travel how old were
you when you got your passport almost
the first country you went to
um I went to Argentina with Playboy
when I was 21. okay that was the first
time out of the country 21. it was my
first time anywhere yeah because I never
traveled sure she's from Arizona Arizona
and California so you had to get your
passport to go I did they even told me I
had to get it and they got it expedited
for me okay because I I didn't ha I
didn't never had gone anywhere before
that do you still have the activation
sticker on any of your cards
you know what I mean that you're
supposed to peel I know that [__] drives
me nuts
hmm okay uh so you do get take out you
you and you and your boyfriend at the
house you get take out from whatever it
gets delivered will you plate that or
will you eat out of the containers you
know I don't do take out I don't like
things delivered
oh wait it's never as good I agree with
you on that it's never as good the tacos
are soggy the pizza's cold the things
that arrive like McDonald's it's just
that doesn't have the same crispiness in
that McMuffin and if I'm gonna eat the
calories I want it to be popping so at
the house except when he would bring
home stuff from the restaurant I cook
that's it 100 of the time really I like
to cook and I don't I like to go out or
cook at home but I don't like post mates
I don't even have doordash or any of
that on my phone it's not an option no
kidding don't like it pretty good uh do
you have a favorite fast food you can't
say in and out burger or Shake Shack
does Waffle House count no no
um but I respect it I had McDonald's
this morning for breakfast you did I did
you're having Mickey D yeah
um what is it called the sausage egg
McMuffin with cheese and a medium coffee
and I had bite of the hash brown it was
a little too greasy for me this morning
it's all right man
sausage McMuffin that's what I had no
this is [__] jury it was so [__]
good hey guys he's got Mickey D's on the
brain I might even have it for dinner
again there you go
uh when was the last time you did a shot
of Fireball oh man Christmas
traditions
okay it's cinnamon but it's like my
family parties yeah let me ask you this
all right
you're in a relationship you and your
boyfriend go out to dinner okay okay
don't
don't screw me on this
you and your boyfriend go out to dinner
I know you order the salmon you have
that you have appetizers you guys share
yourself here what you go you go to a
pizza place it's not a pizza place
what are we doing I want you to settle
something you you act like you you know
hold on I this is [__] no let me let
me let me ask the question you and your
you and your boyfriend go out to a
restaurant that it's an Italian place
that does offer coal-fired Pizza that
does offer is one of the Premier menu
items it's the huge the huge fire thing
the huge Coal Oven that is pronounced
open kitchen so you see it okay
okay you guys go out you have a couple
appetizers you share some ABS comes time
to order the entrees you get the I don't
know the the the carbonara he orders a
pizza yeah do you find that strange
no
thank you I got this dirt bag on my side
no because I would be that Dirtbag that
orders the pizza and I don't want to
share if you want pizza get your own
pizza a pizza is made for one person you
don't think it's weird somebody ordered
a pizza is an entree no I don't probably
orders it in Italian you gotta I get my
own yeah I mean I can't even tell you
how many times I've been out today he
gets a pizza I get a pizza if he wants a
bite of mine that's fine but I'm having
a bite we're doing double zozz down
there I'm never asking that question
again
everybody's been screwing me on it just
wrong you got a bad take on it we even
called the restaurant and they said you
were wrong
it's hard feelings
uh-huh ever seen a UFO
I think so okay
I think so but I was on mushrooms
ah man she's all right
I was on a paddle board in the middle of
ladybird Lake in Austin and I was
looking up into the sky and I swear I
saw you a bow okay hmm okay and it
wasn't just Elon Musk
could have he could have been zipping
around up there that's crazy I took
mushrooms and I swear I met Elon Musk
uh you guys live in Austin
you guys got hand towels in the bathroom
um yeah complete set or you're oh no
it's like the one ring by the uh okay by
the sink and I'm always like sure
putting my makeup and [__] on it so I
have to get a new one every day okay if
you were at home
looks like you can just stab me in the
back on this as well if you were at home
and you were making pasta for you and
your boyfriend okay or if he was making
pasta for you uh would you use and again
this is not the argument if you were
using a Jarred sauce would you use the
whole jar of sauce and a whole box of
pasta or would you use a half a box of
pasta and half of the sauce hold up man
this is not the question the question
when you make pasta did you use the
whole jar but for yourself you're making
one serving of pasta was the is the
question you're doing revisionist
history over here I don't know what to
tell you guys we have company keep me
together
question screw you and her boyfriend I
can tell you guys tell me I cannot
remember the last time I used he makes
homemade Boxed Pasta
or where are you getting the pasta you
make it you're making the pie I already
said that I have so many pasta machines
it's probably unhealthy you got one of
those KitchenAid things I got a
KitchenAid I can make any kind of pasta
you could possibly imagine you got a
Vitamix
um no ninja a ninja you got a ninja
because I make my own sauces what's uh
what's the cookery you got a lot of salt
Maiden made in made in I think I've
heard of that before yeah it's like nice
nice uh ever since I started making
fancy meals sure you gotta you gotta
step up yeah that was a gift for my
boyfriend my boyfriend bought me some
really nice stuff to cook with that's
good
what was the last concert you went to
um
I'm trying to think
I was just I was I was at a country
concert
[Music]
Luke Bryan no jelly roll jelly roll
y
wait it was post Malone ah that was the
last concert and I got to go backstage a
week ago yeah no no I went before that
okay yeah and um there was a Parker
McCollum have you ever heard of him he
was also he was the night before so my
boyfriend knows a famous barbecue
restaurant and so he has some cool
connections nice so we got to go to the
Parker McCollum Country Concert cool and
then the next night was post Malone
shout out to post Malone that was very
really cool he was so nice goddamn show
he played beer pong backstage
he's a good guy what was your first
concert
um Cher
whoa You Believe In Love Tour and Cindy
Lauper opened for her really yeah love
that Cindy Lopper man I mean I'm pretty
good here do you have baking soda in
your refrigerator
in the freezer too no what's the ice
machine situation at the house full okay
can I get it on the door yeah but I
usually just open the door and get it
grab with your hands yeah so you got a
you got a two-door yeah it's double door
freezer on the bottom the ice is on the
top no it's a oh yeah okay double gotcha
all right any milk crates in the house
at the current moment no
you doing a Christmas tree now
you put up a tree I wish no tree no okay
not there yet
you ever cut your own hair
no only back like when I was nine how do
you feel about the rotisserie chicken
what do you mean do you like it yeah
yeah okay I like food though I'm a
foodie you like egg salad yeah you own
binoculars yep
I like to spy on people
and I live in a high-rise where I can
look out the window and I can see all
kinds of things I'm waiting for a
telescope for Christmas okay
uh
uh have you ever crashed someone else's
car
no okay no just my own you wear a CPAP
machine
I'm not a hundred
She's So In Shape she thinks they're for
old people
I'll skip the compression socks question
I have compression socks you do yeah I
wear them on the airplane me too there
you go all right circulation that's
right everywhere
I mean I mean it's a dead uh she speaks
Italian
we think I know she also said I want a
pizza
[Laughter]
I mean she's trash yeah man 100 trash
big time Big Time big time there was a
there was a half a glimpse in the
beginning where I'm like oh she's
already but there really wasn't because
when you said homeschool we were like oh
she's trash then you pulled out of it
for about a half that's what I'm saying
a little Glimpse that's it what's the
trashiest part about me
I mean all of none of it's good the the
Vegas wedding the Vegas wedding the
stealing money from Desperate old men
that's not great uh uh Hooters is a not
a fantastic the GD the geds no coming
back from that that's a good enough
degree
won't you think a sports car is sure
yeah you get your your favorite sports
car you get a [__] Chrysler sports
fire or something
yeah yeah you're trash all right all
right it's okay I had McDonald's this
morning for breakfast
ladies and gentlemen it's Lauren Compton
thank you so much amazing new podcast on
ymh Studios first date show everybody
check it out absolutely fantastic buddy
we love you thank you so much for coming
in thanks for having me this was so much
fun anything else you want the folks out
there to know you can hit him right
there plug socials or anything find me
at I am Lauren Compton on everything
nice Kippy what do you got uh guys we're
all over the road uh shows are selling
out so get your tickets we're announcing
some second shows and third shows and
some four shows in some markets so get
your tickets before they're all gone we
love you we love you gang we'll see you
next week peace